haiya there's a pretty big few
developing between the Eggman and Troy
York here's a voicemail that the egg man
left at two one nine two david p since
yesterday's show Dave I'm so torn true
york's message was so idiotic yet it's
so great that he knows that your
economics professor was richard wolffe
whom i love also sure um Dave I don't
know what the thing about Troy York I
mean the dude hates you but he's
obsessed with you yeah I just want to
know which one of us is gonna get an
invitation to the wedding me or him
right all right Shalom good one and
please don't give me a table if it's
both of them
know if they're both invited to my
hypothetical wedding that doesn't exist
right now
I will not seat them together that's a
pledge I can make yeah I mean I kind of
like Troy work he calls in with like
five different personas and it's always
criticisms of the show and everything
but the guy clearly is a devoted
listener and viewer because he knows
everything that's happening on the
program and we appreciate all of our
audience whether or not you agree with
me political it's just upsetting to me
because Troy York and the eggman the
regular caller yeah and I don't want to
see them beefing I would rather see them
get along that that would be my desire
but I think it is more interesting for
them to be feuding we've got a great
bonus show for you today we're gonna
talk about Neil Gorsuch we will talk
about weather forecasting and we will
talk about a mission to Alpha Centauri
Centauri how do you pronounce Ari
Centauri Alpha Centauri in 2069 get the
bonus show as a patriot as a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
as a member at david pakman.com slash
membership